you're a big ambassador for your
community I certainly a.m. what would
you say McMahon did to your world you
only you'll just start from the
beginning yeah okay in 1992 I owe the
IRS 230 grand I was in Tokyo I couldn't
sleep I was drinking myself a death I
called him my second I have 230 grand he
said yeah I paid RS 1992 right with over
the my divorce and there's at Benson's
amount of things but it means you never
left my side I mean he and I we and it
really came the surface how close we are
when I was sick then sick man face time
to me and talked to me and called Wendy
every day this is a guy they need to be
like you did so only does that make
sense well I didn't bring him anything
except a lot of talent and I was easy to
get along with but I didn't come during
all this 40 years old
what have I gone I was 30 right but that
would change the course of history when
I was getting divorced in 2005 he lent
me $800,000 in increments over a
three-year period to pay the lawyer pay
my ex-wife to live each said I have life
said I wouldn't lend my own son this
damn money mm-hmm
and then he called me and said if you
want to go upside down I won't hold it
against you but I paid him back every
time are you kidding me
stop Pat myself on the back for that but
it was rough his phantom income you
still gotta pay taxes on it it makes
sense of course so eight hundred like
one point they have this guy Luke split
yeah this cake call Wendy every day and
check on me and the first time I saw him
he had tears in his eyes too what's up
with that
I wish the Merry Christmas yell you're
not even supposed to be in service just
I've asked him over the years as you
know a self-confidence problems and
that's why I'm here and I ran our best
friends
every time you used to form your signs
that you can do this when here I am
wrestling in my fifties again touka is
24 years old and I couldn't get I could
still do it physically but he here I'd
lost my self-confidence you physically
can do this mentally you kind of [ __ ]
do it
excuse me no you can't use that worse
all right and that's why I mean I've
heard my best friend you could tell when
he talks about you like he you could see
it in the eyes yeah loves you this is
the guy that he has got so much on his
plate you know he's being taught to be
the next guy he runs NXT he's an
ambassador he and Stephanie travel
around the world I've seen their
schedules representing the company I
mean they don't just sit in a chair and
push button then delegate authority
there they are him Vince he'd it of the
hardest thing I would have to say I've
seen over the years is him delegating
Authority he in but that's who he is and
that's it's worked out for him does that
make sense
hmm very few people does he trusts but
when he does he'll ride it out with you